comment tu allais moi ça va très bien et
je m'apprête à annoncer des choses je me
frotte les mains comme les méchants dans
les films mais là je suis pas un méchant
dans la vidéo juge je suis excité les
gars pas panique c'est moi je sais vous
avez pas reconnu que c'est une vidéo de
moi parce que l'image de la chaîne a
changé donc en voyant la notice vous
êtes dit qu'est ce que c'est que cette
photo su me suis-je abonnés à cette
chaîne je vais me désabonner nathan et
de semer squeeze c'est toujours jumbo
mais c'est jumbo six mois je l'avais
dessine et ça c'est quand mon frère le
dessine il ya une vraie diffa on
l'accueille comme il se doit dans la
communauté mais aussi changer la
bannière nahda n'était pas cool c'est la
texture qu'on utilise sur les lives
twitch ceux qui suivent les lives et les
best-of de la chaîne gaming vous la
connaissez abonnez vous relâchiez gaming
et devinez quoi c'est un lien avec la
vidéo qui suit bah je suis content j'ai
bien travaillé la vidéo qui suit
aujourd'hui un match chacun ce brésil
qui est l' inverse de l'un des premiers
qu'on ait fait souvenez-vous qui
s'appelait crappy design dans celle ci
avait que des erreurs d'ingénieurs des
trucs trop mal pensé trop mal conçu
c'était frustrant aujourd'hui c'est
l'extrême inverse un seul vrai dit
rempli de design géniaux et enfin après
messieurs dames des mois d'attentes
vous êtes en train de regarder la
dernière vidéo de la chaîne avec ce
décor
ça fait quelque chose quand même
j'aimais particulièrement ce décor mais
il est temps de me dire au revoir toutes
les bonnes choses ont une fin
[Musique]
nouveau décor est un décor en 3d que je
vous révèlerai à la fin de cette vidéo
d'ici là profitez bien de ce décor car
c'est la dernière vidéo qu'il contient
franchement ça me fait vraiment quelque
chose bref passons ainsi aubry dit la
campagne les ceintures sauve la vie pas
mal ça en france car finalement sur les
pierres tombales
sauf que là la date de décès est caché
par cette ceinture comme si elle
permettait finalement de la repousser si
vous le souhaitez j'analyse toutes les
images comme ça personne n'a voulu en
parlant de ceinture de sécurité et donc
de sécurité routière même ont traumatisé
mois les pubs à l'époque de sécurité
routière on voit des gens heureux que la
minute d'après décès dans les flops de
la ola j'avais 9 ans et demi tonne mais
vous décidez grâce à toutes ces pubs et
ceux de ma génération qu'entre chez pas
18 et 25
et même plus jeunes en fait je pense ils
ont vraiment fait du bon taf parce que
ça a eu un vrai impact genre tout ce
qu'est l'alcool au volant le téléphone
au volant et toutes les pubs choc qu'ils
ont faites moi ils m'ont vraiment matrix
et jamais de la vie j'ai bu une goutte
d'alcool avant de prendre la moto où la
voiture
ouais j'suis un biker alors que mine de
rien dans la génération ne serait ce que
nos parents s'étaient méga fréquents je
me suis souvenu de trucs quand j'étais
plus petit ou cerveau se réunissent et
il ya plein de gens quand ils partaient
il avait bu et prenez la voiture et
personne ne disait rien c'est n'importe
quoi
au lhc petite minute où je disais de
troisième dans ça me fait plaisir j'ai
trouvé cette tableau oiseaux très
charmante effectivement mignonne sobre
efficace
je la mets pas chez moi cette pub de
noël pour mercedes waouh regardez moi
cette lumière qui tombe sur ce qui
paraît être l'avant d'une mercedes très
mal un très beau très élégant mercedes
lewis hamilton est ce que j'ai regardé
le documentaire des flics sur la f1 oui
est-ce que je prétends est un grand
passionné de f1 depuis ben bien sûr un
potentiel nouveau design intéressant
d'un billet de 20 dollars
or pas mal ça reprend le fait qu'ils
aient marchés en premier sur la lune
ça reprend aussi john kennedy pourquoi
je n'ai pas la moindre idée peut-être
c'est le président favori des américains
quoi qu'il en soit ces dons laissez-nous
n'oubliez vintage un peu millions sur
lesquels l'un des visages de gens que
les incultes comme moi ne connaissent
pas c'est excellent il ya beaucoup tout
n'y a pas de marque au canada
tous les produits sont tellement sobre
qu'à chaque fois je me tape une barre
quand je vais faire des courses
ah bah oui on veut un carrefour puis on
tape des grandes barres dans les rayons
piranhas plantes c'est ça ouais à qui tu
veux faire gober ça ouah c'est hyper
cool en vrai je bois un cola tu veux du
cocoa danton les voilà une brique de jus
de pomme en tout cas moi je vous
avoue je suis très partisan des design
méga sobre mais à condition que tout le
monde ne se mettent pas à faire des
design média sort auquel cas ça devient
un peu cryptique les céréales boffin
pour la santé mais moi j'adore et je
devrai vent le lapin de coco pops
c'est un lapin comme je prétends avoir
une enfance que je n'ai pas eue c'est
possible qu'une pub pour réduire la
consommation d'électricité
les mecs ont éteint tous les spots sauf
le dernier sous lequel ils ont marqué
utiliser l'électricité wisely chez pas
ce que ça veut dire j'ai gâché la fin de
cette phrase c'est gras efficace
franchement beau gosse la pub mcdonald's
pour la saint-valentin aussi un burger
je me sens mal je n'ai pas vu pendant un
bon moment
c'est non inondables ou quoi moi je
trouve ça creepy commencez pas à rouler
des pelles à vauvert gard devant on va
pas être atteint je vous le dis tout de
suite ce logo incroyablement créatif
alors nous on est une agence de voyages
vachement were on aimerait un logo qui
traduit un peu ce côté aware et puis
entre le bright et le shadow tu vois ce
que je veux
franchement bien joué il ya beaucoup de
travail on se rend pas compte des rats
les logos le taf qu'il ya même des
relais de gaulle est plus simple c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que les entreprises à
ces grandes cases achète un logo ça leur
coûte très cher donc si vous voulez
gagner très beaucoup d'argent fait des
logos pour les compagnies qui sont très
grosses assas a fait le tour du monde
sur freighter foundation une pub pour
sushi regarder ce qui va dans l'océan se
retrouve en toi très très malin vraiment
j'ai l'argent qu'à chaque fois les
associations c'est celle qui se creuse
le plus la tête et qui font les trucs
les plus innovants et ouf en fait
puisqu'elle peut vraiment quel choc en
un clin d'oeil à regarder en parler de
logo c'est le logo d'un restaurant
japonais qui représente à la fois
quelqu'un qui tient des baguettes mais
aussi une grue japonaise sur le fond qui
est le drapeau du japon
c'est un 10 sur 10 logo vos traits à les
lieux comme ça qu'on va que j'avais
failli faire une vidéo sur ça mais avec
le cowitz trop déprimant genre on les
voit on fait un trou béant ce lieu
j'adorerais y aller
voix superbe à moitié dans l'eau pencher
comme vraiment beau très beau lieu je
n'aurais jamais la chance d'y aller une
pub adidas qui met en garde contre les
faux produits
le fait que ça fait vraiment mal les
imitations sont faites à larache ça ne
vous donne aucune protection
or ils ont mis les pansements mode les
trois bandes du logo adidas
ce pied me dégoûte tu veux sortir mon
petit chat tu veux sortir
ok tu sors à jumbo jumbo plus le temps
passe et puis là cet est dans la vraie
vie c'est un truc de fou ou aaa
tiens pour changer un peu le design d'un
pont qui s'appelle golden bridge situé
au vietnam très fort très très fort j'ai
un besoin comme ça c'est le genre d'idée
qu'un mec à et ses supérieurs le regarde
et lui disent non c'est non hélas les
supérieurs ont dit c'est oui excellente
idée c'est génial au studio ghibli est
ce que ça m'étonne qu'ils soient dans ce
ne réédite pas du tout studio ghibli à
design et cette boîte de dvd dans
laquelle on dirait que les personnages
regardent leur reflet dans la réflexion
de l'eau sauf qu'en fait c'est pas de
l'eau c'est le cd dans lequel il ya
vraiment le reflet des deux personnages
dr watashi wa djihad watashi wa ni en
jean desse watashi wa néant jean desse
non non transformé à l'offre
industrielle en lofts habitable veut
transformer le genou ligne ça tue jaloux
s'il ya des gens qui font des études
d'architecte d'intérieur et ben je vous
déteste c'est une vocation que je trouve
trop belle
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour vous je
vous aime réellement et je me souhaite
le meilleur pour vos études dans cette
période compliquée voilà je suis avec
vous les mecs se sont creusé la tête
pour faire une petite gomme qui sort du
lot cela c'est une gomme qui au fil de
l'usaj se transforme en mont fuji
offrez la mois a encore une campagne
cette fois pour inciter les gens à
donner leurs organes quand ils meurent
ils n'ont pas besoin de partir avec vous
donnez vos organes encore un truc où
c'est la sensibilité de chacun mois pour
le coup j'avoue je les donnerai quitte à
crever autant aider quelqu'un qui n'a
pas encore crevé oh non c'est une pub
jeep pendant le coït genre tout le monde
est enfermé chez soi mais il essaie de
vendre des voitures quand même j -p
avec un peu de patience la vue ne sera
que meilleur mais je vous prends même
pas la pub la ola je fatigue et allez
hop
désolé jeep à ça j'avais déjà vu ses
excellents encore une fois architecte
d'intérieur vous êtes des bosses ou nul
à chier vous ne savez pas vous enfermez
pas des lits superposés mai
ils maintiennent la vie privée de chacun
en mettant un mur la roë un mur là en
bas c'est excellent cette chemise à des
boutons à l'intérieur pour éviter le
trou de poitrine tant redoutée c'est
quoi le trou de poitrine tant redouté
j'ai pas la rêve c'est normal je n'ai
pas de seins imagine quand il pleut or
quand je suis pas le seul à avoir ce
méga kif
il ya un truc chimiques dans mon corps
qui se passe quand il pleut dehors à
torrent et que moi je suis chez moi et
j'entends les goûts de taper sur tout
les velux de mon appart je suis
tellement o'keefe d'avoir un instinct
hommes de cro magnon de ces quand
j'étais dans la grotte et que ça
s'écoute et que j'adore ça et je
kifferais dormir là dedans joly ouah
mais quel beau gosse et une la carte de
visite d'un avocat spécialisé dans les
divorces lé prix découpé pour qu'elles
se déchireront deux échoppes parti à les
coordonnées de l'avocat ya forcément des
mecs qui voulait pas divorcer mais qui
en voyant la carte de visite ont divorcé
pour bosser avec cela c'est sur une pub
intéressante de jeep
les gars je comprends pas les publics je
suis vraiment pas fait pour avoir une
chips à 6 hockey en modèle et tout
terrain elle balaye tous types de
terrains danané ok ça ne m'intéresse pas
bon messieurs dames
il est temps passé aux rives il du
nouveau décor 3d
[Musique]
alors ça fait quelque chose
je suis et bulles vous montrer ça ça
fait des mois qu'on bosse là dessus il
est pas méga complexe et justement c'est
pour ça que ça a pris autant de temps à
faire c'est le bon dosage de chad truc
que j'aime barges et vous passez en
détail les amants décor non mais
regardez moi cette verdure sans déconner
ça fait pas du bien à l'esprit mais je
rêve ou sur les deux murs aux extrémités
le mec a mis sa texture
je vous ai dit j'adore cette élection oh
c'est un clin d'oeil à un arrêt à
l'aventuré vous avez vécu avec lui
j'étais obligé de le mettre dans ce
décor vul aventure qui nous a fait vivre
à jamais dans mon coeur à l'arrêt peuple
a juste à côté beaucoup moins titulaire
c'est le pot dégueulasse que j'avais
fait dans la vidéo poterie juste à côté
c'est aussi ce que beaucoup parmi vous
ont pour de vrai chez eux dans une
étagère
ces trois là mais les emmener avec moi
les gars enfin jacky dwayne et hommes
ils quitteront jamais 20 ans des micros
bouquet de fleurs dans des bocaux
transparent même bien un peu à des
macros c'est un truc que j'ai gardées
l'ancien décor c'est le globe terrestre
et oui qui étaient déjà là avant
souvenez vous juste à côté une figurine
de goldorak 2,7 sous merde que j'ai pour
de vrai au studio et que j'ai voulu
remettre là dans le décor ce que je
trouve vraiment incroyable en dessous on
a des livres on aime petit game boy un
peu cliché un peu trop cliché une petite
fenêtre à gauche on avait une avance sur
la droite de l'image et j'aime bien ça
crée une ouverture dans le fond une
porte très important je vous jure ça
permet de respirer j'ai des versions n'y
a pas de porte d'à j'étouffe sur la
droite et un petit étendard avec des
vêtements hashtag à dioko le petit tapis
par terre ensuite on a des petites
lumières tamisées à gauche à droite et
aussi au mieux on a remis un instrument
à vent n'avait un banjo cette forme d'un
ukulélé avec la texture dessus et au mur
évidemment mais deux affiches préféré
yoko qu'il ya pour de vrai dans mon
décor de la vie qui sont vraiment au mur
enfin bon voilà il est assez sobre en
fin de compte ce décor met dedans y'a
que des trucs que j'aime je trouve hyper
chaleureux hyper goodbye ça fait plaisir
et puis aussi petite surprise on a une
version serait d'horreur du décor pour
laisserait d'horreur qui apparaît
maintenant à l'écran voilà c'est
exactement le même décor mais en version
des structures et usé plus raccord du
coup avec cette vidéo serait doha
je suis très content c'était un plaisir
de bosser avec quentin deronzier du coup
qu'a fait ce décor je me doute que pour
le mans ça vous fait bizarre et c'est
normal on a tourné peut-être 50 ou 100
vidéos dans l'ancien décor mais j'suis
sûr vous allez vous habituer moi je le
trouve vraiment cool donc j'ai aucun
doute surfer qui vous plaisent voilà
portez vous bien à très vite dans
d'autres vidéos
merci à vous regarder le tour n'a pas
changé c'est la même si la masse qui
tourne mais je pense que lui trop c'est
un truc qu'on gens
je vous fais un bisou de maman
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]